En 2013, era una ejecutiva en una firma internacional de ingeniería
en San Francisco.
Era mi trabajo soñado.
Un conjunto de todas las habilidades que adquirí en los años fueron:
contar historias, impacto social y cambio de comportamiento.
Era la jefa del mercadeo y la cultura
y trabajé con los sistemas de salud más grandes de la nación,
usando cambios tecnológicos y culturales
para reducir radicalmente su uso de energía y agua
y mejorar su impacto social.
Estaba haciendo un cambio real en el mundo.
Pero fue la peor experiencia profesional de mi vida.
Choqué contra la pared muy duro.
Dolió como el demonio.
Mientras había problemas más graves,
lo que pasó principalmente fueron pequeñas conductas y patrones
que poco a poco disolvieron mi habilidad de trabajar bien.
Se comieron mi confianza, mi liderazgo, mi capacidad de innovar.
Por ejemplo, mi primera presentación en la compañía.
Caminé hasta el frente de la sala
para dar una presentación de las tácticas que yo creía mejor para la compañía.
Esa para la cual me contrataron.
Y observé la sala, a mis colegas ejecutivos.
Y miré cómo tomaban sus teléfonos
y miraban a sus portátiles.
No prestaban atención.
Ni bien comencé a hablar, empezaron las interrupciones
y la gente hablaba por encima de mí una y otra vez.
Algunas de mis ideas fueron rechazadas en seguida
y luego las dijo alguien más y las defendieron.
Era la única mujer en esa sala.
Me hubiera venido bien un aliado.
Pequeñas conductas y patrones como este, cada día, una y otra vez,
te desgastan.
Muy pronto, mis energías estaban totalmente explotadas.
En una etapa muy baja, leí un artículo
acerca de la cultura de lugares de trabajos tóxicos y microagresiones.
Microagresiones... desprecios, insultos,
comunicación negativa verbal y no verbal,
sea intencional o no,
que impiden tu capacidad de trabajar bien.
Eso sonaba familiar.
Me empecé a dar cuenta de que no estaba fallando.
La cultura a mi alrededor estaba fallándome.
Y no estaba sola.
Conductas y patrones como este a diario
afectan a personas subrepresentadas en todos los espacios laborales.
Y eso tiene un impacto real
en nuestros colegas, nuestras compañías
y nuestra capacidad colectiva de innovar.
En la industria tecnológica queremos soluciones rápidas.
Pero no hay varita mágica para corregir la diversidad e inclusión.
El cambio empieza una persona a la vez,
un acto a la vez, una palabra a la vez.
Cometemos un error cuando vemos la diversidad y la inclusión
como un proyecto secundario en el que las personas de las diversidades trabajan,
en vez de este trabajo dentro de todos que debemos hacer juntos.
Y ese trabajo comienza
con desaprender lo que sabemos del éxito y las oportunidades.
Nos han dicho toda nuestra vida
que si trabajamos duro esto será recompensado,
que obtendremos lo que merecemos, que viviremos nuestro sueño.
Pero esa no es la verdad para todos.
Algunos tienen que trabajar 10 veces más duro
para llegar al mismo lugar
por las muchas barreras que les pone en frente la sociedad.
Tu género, tu raza, tu etnicidad,
tu religión, tu discapacidad, tu orientación sexual,
tu clase, tu geografía,
todo esto puede dar más o menos oportunidades para el éxito.
Ahí es donde entra el apoyo.
El apoyo es entender ese desequilibrio en las oportunidades
y trabajar para corregirlo.
El apoyo es ver a la persona a nuestro lado.
Y la persona que falta y debería estar parada a nuestro lado.
Primero, solo saber por lo que están pasando.
Y entonces, ayudarlos a tener éxito y prosperar con nosotros.
Cuando trabajamos juntos para desarrollar equipos más diversos e inclusivos,
eso muestra que seremos más innovadores, más productivos y más lucrativos.
Así que, ¿quién puede servir de apoyo?
Todos.
Podemos ser apoyo para cada uno.
Como una mujer blanca cisgénero en los Estados Unidos,
hay muchas formas en las cuales soy privilegiada.
Y algunas en las que no.
Trabajo duro a diario
para ser un apoyo para la gente con menos privilegios que yo.
Aunque también yo necesite apoyo.
En la industria tecnológica, como en muchas industrias,
hay muchas personas que son subrepresentadas
o enfrentan barreras y discriminación.
Las mujeres, personas no-binarias,
personas que no se identifican como hombre o mujer,
minorías raciales y étnicas,
LGBTQIA, personas discapacitadas, veteranos,
cualquiera sobre los 35 años.
(Risas)
Tenemos un mayor prejuicio sobre los jóvenes en la industria tecnológica.
Y muchos otros.
Siempre hay alguien con menos privilegios que tú.
En este escenario, en esta sala.
En tu compañía, en tu equipo, en tu ciudad o pueblo.
Las personas son apoyo por diferentes razones.
Encuentra tu razón.
Podría ser por negocios,
porque las cifras muestran que equipos más diversos e inclusivos
son más productivos, más lucrativos y más innovadores.
Podría ser por la equidad y justicia social.
Porque tenemos una larga historia de opresión e inequidad
en la que debemos trabajar juntos.
O podría ser para tus niños,
para que tus niños crezcan con oportunidades iguales.
Y crezcan creando oportunidades iguales para otros.
Encuentra tu motivo.
Para mí, son las tres.
Encuentra tu motivo y da un paso para estar ahí cuando alguien necesite.
¿Qué puedes hacer como apoyo?
Empieza por no hacer daño.
Es nuestro trabajo saber qué son las microagresiones y no hacerlas.
Es nuestro trabajo como apoyo escuchar, aprender,
desaprender y volver a aprender,
cometer errores y seguir aprendiendo.
Presten atención.
Cierren sus portátiles,
dejen sus teléfonos y presten atención.
Si alguien es nuevo, o es la única persona como ellos en la sala,
o solo están nerviosos,
esto hará una gran diferencia en cómo se muestran.
No interrumpas.
Las personas subrepresentadas son más propensas a ser interrumpidas,
así que da un paso atrás y escucha.
Resuena y atribuye.
Si tengo una buena idea,
resuena mi idea y atribúyemela, y así prosperamos juntos.
Aprende el lenguaje que uso para describir mi identidad.
Cómo pronunciar mi nombre.
Conoce mis pronombres -- él, ella, ellos.
Conoce el lenguaje que uso para describir mis discapacidades, mi etnia, mi religión.
Esto les importa mucho a las personas, y si no sabes, solo pregunta.
Escucha y aprende.
Un ejecutivo recientemente me dijo que después de dar apoyo a su equipo,
todo el equipo empezó a llamarse mutuamente la atención
si alguien interrumpía.
"Perdón por interrumpirte ahora mismo, continúa".
"Hey, ella tiene una buena idea, escuchen".
Número 2, defiende a las personas subrepresentadas de pequeñas maneras.
Actúa; puedes cambiar la dinámica de poder en la sala.
Si ves a alguien que es la única persona como ellos en la sala
y están siendo menospreciados, están siendo interrumpidos,
haz algo, di algo.
Invita a las personas subrepresentadas a hablar.
Y di no a paneles sin hablantes subrepresentados.
Refiere a alguien para un trabajo
y anímalos a tomar ese trabajo, a tomar nuevas oportunidades.
Y esta es de verdad importante: ayuda a normalizar el apoyo.
Si eres una persona con privilegios,
es fácil para ti abogar por apoyo.
Usa ese privilegio para crear un cambio.
Tres, cambia la vida de alguien significativamente.
Estar ahí para alguien durante toda su carrera.
Sirve de mentor o patrocínalos, dales oportunidades mientras crecen.
Sé voluntario -- para programa STEM, sirviendo a juventud marginada.
Transforma tu equipo para que sea más diverso e inclusivo.
Y haz compromisos reales para crear un cambio aquí.
Manténte a ti y a tu equipo responsable por crear cambio.
Y por último,
ayuda a abogar por el cambio a través de tu compañía.
Cuando las compañías enseñan a sus empleados a ser aliados,
los programas de diversidad e inclusión son más fuertes.
Tú y yo podemos ser apoyo mutuo,
ya sea dentro o fuera del trabajo.
Por lo tanto, me di cuenta recientemente
que todavía persiste la vergüenza y el miedo
de ese momento en mi carrera cuando me sentí totalmente sola,
silenciada y sin apoyo.
Hay millones de personas allá fuera como yo, ahora mismo, sintiéndose así.
Y no toma mucho de nosotros estar ahí para otros.
Y cuando estamos ahí para otros, cuando nos apoyamos entre nosotros,
progresamos juntos.
Y cuando progresamos, construimos mejores equipos,
mejores productos y mejores compañías.
El apoyo es poderoso.
Pruébenlo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)